les premiers flocons de l'année 2017
sont tombés ce lundi de janvier
placés en vigilance orange par météo
france avec 17 autres départements les
yvelines ont observé quelques chutes de
neige en fin de matinée poursuivi depuis
là le tout début de journée une
perturbation assez faible qui défend des
dunes ordre qui est qui glisse à vernon
donc elle a d'abord touché le val d'oise
ensuite le nord des divines et puis
ensuite est arrivé sur sur la sur saint
quentin en yvelines donc en fait d'abord
nous quelques petites pluies mais
ensuite cette petite pluie on se sont
transformées en pluie et neige mêlées et
la cudl un épisode de courte durée la
neige n'a pas tenu et la vigilance
orange a été levée en milieu de journée
mais les services techniques du
département restent en alerte
il couvre une trentaine de communes pour
le centre de saint cyr l'école nous
avons
quatre camions
pour le service hivernal et chaque
camion fait 4 mètres cubes 4 mètres
cubes équivaut à peu près 10 rabbit hole
l'enjeu est une question de sécurité
pour les usagers pour qu'ils puissent en
fait le nir au travail à partir de 6
heures le matin
or toute sécurité météo france prévoit
de nouvelles gelé dans la nuit avec un
risque de brouillard givrant et des
températures entre -4 et -2 degrés
attention donc au verglas et aux plaques
de glace une prudence à respecter pour
le reste de la semaine